des centaines de numéros d'assurance
maladie liée à des rendez-vous pour des
vaccins contre la coved 19 se sont
avérées facilement accessibles sur
internet
c'est un membre de la communauté du axe
est un groupe de personnes intéressées
par la cyber sécurité qui a fait la
découverte ses membres mettent
régulièrement la main sur ce genre
d'information nous on transige show
gouvernement pour régler le problème de
manière transparente et responsable si
l'on peut dire pour porte justement les
criminels tombe sur soi par hasard le
ministère de la santé affirme qu'une
erreur de manipulation humaine est à
l'origine de la fuite de ces données il
ajoute toutefois qu' à partir des
informations contenues dans le document
il était impossible d'obtenir l'identité
d'une personne son nom aussi coordonner
et donc l'identité des citoyens n'a pas
été compromise
la porte parole du ministère explique
aussi que bien que cet événement n'est
pas causé de préjudice
le ministère a revu ses faces ont
procédé avec les centres de vaccination
afin d'éviter qu'une telle situation se
reproduise
même si aucune conséquence n'a été
rapporté cette fois ci les experts
s'interrogent sur les efforts consacrés
à la cybersécurité dans l'élaboration de
logiciels si ce problème là existent
combien d'autres problèmes existent dans
leur logiciel de tricks sortie 6 a
rapporté david gill ans de certaines
personnes
elle aurait pu avoir ici exploitation
malicieuse et encore une fois sarkozy
des torts à la population pour eux il
est facile de faire le parallèle avec
l'incident survenu il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine dans le guichet d'accès
aux places en services de garde plate 05
que la place 5-0 août l'ex nantais c'est
la même problématique c'est le manque
d'analysé en sécurité coeur que
professionnel patrick mathieu croit donc
une intervention gouvernementale est
nécessaire
cette intervention devrait prendre la
forme d'une loi obligeant les
organisations publiques ou privées à
faire de la cyber sécurité une priorité
dans l'élaboration d'outils numériques
ici cassandra nadeau la marche
radio canada québec